hi I'm Liz and I'm from the Midwest
where we eat cheese curds when I moved
out to Los Angeles I realized that most
people have never had these squeaky
delights so I took to the streets of
Hollywood to see if these people were
worth their cheddar hey what's up I'm
Justin I'm Shawn and we from South
Africa I'm Brian from Treasure Island
Florida South Dakota so not forgotten
Long Island from LA
Virginia affa California Hollywood
Alaska Texas Chicago Illinois and I have
never had a cheese curd let's fondue
this what does it look like to you
uh yeah wax oh is this really cheesy I
don't know isn't there like moldy cheese
soggy cheese huh
oh I don't know and that is hmm
that's nolle Wow but it's delicious it's
like a cheese fry not a huge fan it's
really rubbery a cross between a
Velveeta and a Easy Mac made in a little
girl's oven bacon oh I love it
it's rad that it squeaks when you chew I
can't do any more not bad it's like the
orgasm in your mouth I'd have them
constantly I thought it was been gonna
taste like it honestly yeah it's
actually much better than I thought it
was going to be it's way better than
normal cheese way better than normal
cheese what I would have them again and
again and again and again over the world
I didn't like the texture can I try one
more it's too rubbery too chewy
never again ever again it'll be great to
get this in South Africa I would like to
make a cheese curd pizza what can I get
this would you guys eat this again I
would definitely eat him again number
one I love it yeah right here right here
definitely I give it a ten top ten can I
have some all all right guys here's the
cheese curd taste test breakdown we got
a lot of these some of these some of
these and some of these people are
pretty much all over the board but
either way I think everyone had a good
time
sorry that was cheesy
you